i mean it's just cause i'm so as someone
from england
and basically you know all of europe and
also asia
it's pretty safe to walk around here
yeah and anywhere you
you try to you if you need to go home or
walk to a new bar
you just walk there yeah in america if
you go you can be at the like the nicest
bar
and one block away you can get shot or
something if you just take a wrong turn
i was so scared walking in san francisco
at like 1am i was like oh my god i'm
going to die
i'm going i'm texting my friends being
like you can have my stuff bro take my
youtube channel like it's all over
here's the possibility yeah it's one am
at san fran bro i'm dead yeah yeah
yeah and i remember it was i think it
was ax two years ago where we
we had a hotel suite and we also had an
airbnb yeah and it was only
like five minutes walk away from each
other oh my god but the airbnb was so
scary
it was wasn't it it was a [ __ ] great
airbnb
it was like the it was like it was like
the chillest airbnb we had a [ __ ]
pool table and everything yeah but it
was
it just seemed like in the dodgiest area
that was where like the homeless guy
thing happened
because i remember i remember like we
were gonna go to your airbnb like a
house party and you gave me the
coordinates i'm like oh it's just down
the road
so we just start walking and i'm just
like it's telling me to turn into this
alleyway
and then i'm just like nah gosh it's
[ __ ] just it just gets darker and
darker and darker
because i remember i invited john super
eye patchwolf to the party as well
and i gave him like the general area
right and he was having trouble finding
it
and um i remember trying to run out to
try and get him to
get to go come to the party yeah and he
was like down the road so all he saw
was some guy coming out in like this
dark alleyway shouting
john
he just [ __ ] turns around and just
walks the other corner
i can't imagine what he was thinking i'm
out of here
not not today not today oh my god that
was where like the homeless guy
the one i i pushed over a homeless guy
that sounds terrible i didn't fight him
i just pushed him over this sounds
terrible by the way
just going around pushing over homeless
people so like it was like 3am and i was
walking to the hotel from the airbnb and
it was already sketchy as [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah and there was like a woman
crying on the floor in a corner
and like this guy with no shirt on just
shorts
like tattoos all over he was like five
foot
like four foot ten yeah very small as
[ __ ] and he was like
malnourished he had like no teeth and he
was just screaming at this girl
like threatening her in the corner and i
was like well [ __ ] i have to like say
something
yeah and so in my awkward british self i
was like hey um
could you could you stop doing that i
think she doesn't like it it's like what
i said right yeah
he's like who the [ __ ] you think you are
man who the [ __ ] you think you're like
talking to me he's like he's like i
think he's like hispanic or something
yeah yeah
and and he was like like squaring up to
me and i was like look that man come on
just leave her alone man like she's
clearly like
not wanting to talk to you yeah when i
say talk he was just screeching at her i
don't know what happened she was
crying and so when he comes over to me
she runs off
yeah great she's gone she's safe yeah
and then
like from what i can remember at the
time because a little drunk a bit
yeah he like is like this close to me
yeah
shouting in my face and i'm like okay
what's gonna happen here i'm just gonna
walk away now
yeah and so like he grabs something from
his pocket i don't know what he's gonna
do so i just push him over and run away
yeah
jesus christ cause i'm like [ __ ] i don't
know what this guy's gonna do
like i'm scared as [ __ ] i don't know
what's happening i would not have the
balls to like be like hey could you can
you stop please like
because she was like it was like no one
else around and this girl was
crying her eyes out yeah well hey hey
man
hey could you could you stop it like
basically yeah then he got really angry
at me and i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay and then i thought he was gonna
like hit me or something
if i see someone reaching for that
pocket like that i'd do exactly
he didn't swing at me or anything but he
was going for his pocket and i'm like
i literally [ __ ] sprinted away i like
ran around the corner
in my hotel i'm like yeah
yeah and like to put this in perspective
like again our airbnb was like five
minutes away from
the intercontinental yeah or something
like some like very famous hotel shape
yeah so
you just don't get something like this
here or like in europe so we
we are just not used to this that you
have to literally take you literally
drive
five minutes down the road not even five
minutes down the road because it's a
five minute walk yeah just because this
this is the [ __ ] that happens
that can happen in between yeah i
learned my lesson just at that time just
probably not walking around
yeah don't intervene if you're not
willing to push someone over i guess
i don't really know i didn't feel great
about pushing it over because he was way
smaller than me
yeah but like i don't know i mean but if
you never know if he was gonna like just
pull out a gun the guy
clearly was on something yeah yeah he
was out of it like
spawning nonsense like he wasn't talking
english like i mean he was trying to but
you know i mean i don't know what he was
on but it was scary it's terrifying yeah
is there anything you want to talk about
or is that where we should be
i'm not trying to demonize homeless
people i think most of them are super
chill and really nice i just had there's
one or two interactions to get the [ __ ]
out of me
before people in case there are any
homeless people watching yeah
i think he's cool with you guys it's all
right also any americans as well
oh yeah yeah we say all this [ __ ] about
americans in america but like
we we're okay with you guys this is just
the culture shock that we get
whenever whenever we visit there exactly
like that
you guys are cool right for a lot of the
time i love you america you're great
yeah you're very entertaining
always than one we just we just have a
lot of great stories to tell whenever we
go there